J'essaie vraiment d'être la meilleure version
de moi-même, d'inspirer totalement quelqu'un d'autre
à être la meilleure version d'
eux-mêmes.  re quand vous voyez l'injustice sous
quelque forme que ce soit si vous savez que quelqu'un est
victime d'intimidation ou quoi que vous sachiez, vous vous levez
et vous utilisez votre voix et vous
ne vous contentez pas de rester assis
[Musique]
Je dirais que le numéro un vous entoure
de personnes positives qui  vont
vous aider à arriver là où vous voulez aller pour vous
assurer que vous aimez vraiment ce que vous faites
parce que ça ne va pas être facile, il va y
avoir des moments difficiles, donc vous devez vraiment vous
assurer que vous avez une passion pour ça
et trois aller  pour ça, quand j'ai commencé à
danser, j'étais comme oh c'était horrible, je
ne pouvais pas, je ne pouvais pas suivre tous les
autres enfants, c'est vraiment mauvais,
mais je travaille d'arrache-pied et je suis devenu bon, donc
ça prend juste de la pratique
[Musique]
pour moi, ça a toujours été une
chose inspirante, vous savez ce que je veux dire
quand je vois des femmes de couleur dans n'importe quel type de
capacité, je fais vraiment leur
truc et je travaille dur et et et je
ne le fais pas  savent exceller dans leur carrière, donc
je pense que pour moi, cela a toujours été une source
d'inspiration et je sais que j'essaie de vous savez,
même si j'ai 18 ans, je pense que je devrais
toujours essayer de faire ça pour la jeune
génération
[Musique]
Je veux  dire que vous savez que cette
génération est, je pense, le
type de groupe le plus ouvert d'esprit que
nous ayons, je pense que c'est parce qu'avec les
médias sociaux avec tout ce que vous ne pouvez pas vraiment
cacher de certains sujets et vous
ne pouvez pas prétendre que  vous ne voyez pas ce que
les gens font, ce qui se passe et
ce que les gens traversent dans le
monde, ce qui est plutôt sympa, je pense que les
médias sociaux pour les mauvaises choses, mais
quand nous les utilisons pour la bonne chose,
nous pensons que c'est extrêmement puissant
[Musique]
quelle que soit l'inspiration que je peux fournir et
offrir et les portes que je peux ouvrir ou quoi que je
puisse faire, je vais certainement essayer de
[Musique]